Michael remembers exactly what went
through his head the day he was
diagnosed with HIV it was in January
last year he knew his life had changed
forever you know not only is it my first
thought was will I still be able to find
work oh no I'm positive I had this idea
of jumping off a bridge I was thinking
oh my god I need to die oh my god I need
to die
Michael is 21 and one of some 35,000
people known to live with HIV in the
Philippines he fears being stigmatized
so he asked us not to show his face as a
teenager he sold sex to other men often
without using a condom knowledge about
HIV and how the virus is transmitted is
still patchy among many Filipinos the
ignorance leads not only to higher
infection rates but also feeds fear and
rejection after years of playing down
how severely hiv/aids is impacting young
men like Michael the government now
seems to be changing course
critics have already forced officials to
scrap the idea of making condoms
available at schools they're afraid it
would encourage children to become
promiscuous conservatives say sex
education doesn't belong in the
classroom the first teachers of the
children are their parents for heaven's
sake the parents are not only supposed
to give them food board and lodging but
also to teach them value system
behavioral patterns etc etc to be good
members of society sexual education it
belongs to the parish themselves it's
not an approach Michael things can work
neither parents nor teenagers feel
comfortable talking about sex he himself
has become a peer educator he wants to
spare other young people his fatal agama
goombah say everything starts with
knowing once people have adequate
knowledge
right information about hiv/aids teen
pregnancy condoms and other things
you'll be armed your knowledge will be
your shield and your sword that way you
can protect yourself and at the same
time protect other young people
especially those who are close to you
John Michael knows he's facing an uphill
battle but for him every HIV case he can
prevent by sharing what he's had to
learn the hard way is a victory